TJ Miller's here how's it going man good
to see you
I like your reactive sweater yeah you
look great it's a sweater jacket sup man
I'll go psycho sweater pleasure okay
yeah I see where you go and I see what
you put in there buddy we RAM where my
wife and I think you're gonna get a
place like six blocks from the Comedy
Cellar I really will be hopefully we'll
be in
hopefully we'll be in New York a lot
more I know what's motivating in a movie
that I like New York more than Los
Angeles pleasure and can't stay in Los
Angeles not I mean it's getting it gets
easier and you like it more and more
they say it takes three years to even
like it and five years to be okay sort
of to start really finding things that
you love about it but New York has
always been my wife and I met in college
and it was always our dream to live in
New York because I actually followed
Artie [ __ ] I don't know if I've told
you the story but I came here for the
first time to visit Kate after college
and I went to Dangerfield's which I know
is it is that so close yeah I love that
I want to go back there cuz I so I went
there and I saw already fork washed show
up he was just drinking water he like
stretching and I said you know I got a
9:15 at the Comedy Cellar so I got you
know I got to go up next and he went up
and just killed ya and then left and I
suddenly realized you could do a bunch
of different sets and a night yeah so
then I wanted to follow him there was
another comic who I sort of said hey I'm
a new comic and he goes well I'm going
down to the cellar so then I went down
the cellar and saw already on stage
killing with some of the same material
and some different material and that's
when I just I thought that being in New
York comic was the coolest thing that
you could ever yeah that was a good run
from the cellar to danger feels to
because you can go up first avenue to
Dangerfield's on 60th and first and
right back down the FDR or second avenue
to get to this cell that's up that's a
pretty good run to make on a week I mean
yeah and it's and it's it's that it's
like I want to know that and how many
sets do you do a night now now I do saw
because you have to wake up early right
I do I'll do one a night and when the
most I was doing when I lived in New
Jersey to pay my rent I was doing
six on Friday and seven on Saturday take
sides in my field for Daisy field
reseller and three Dangerfield reseller
on the Friday I paid my rent like that
for why my record is ten here and six in
Los Angeles and yeah anyway Nellie's got
because really you have to do an open
mic you know in the really early open
mic and then just have a car like an
uber wait for you and every show has to
be able to put you up next which yeah
they were very nice that night because
they knew that I was trying to warm up
for like a late-night show spot mom and
but it was 10:00 here because I used to
play the ha comedy club true in Times
Square yeah they would have a show every
hour I think starting at 6:30 so at six
thirty seven thirty eight three in
different room in 30 yet two rooms going
back and forth so they could sort of
turn over one room and you know start
have already started the other one so
what I would do is I would open you know
like the 7:30 show then leave
immediately go to an alt room and then
come back and close the other show 6:30
from the in the other room and then I
would open the show that they turn over
so by doing that I could go back and
forth and do ten sets because you could
do there alone in a night they put you
on every show you could do six sets okay
that's going to be amazing eyes I mean I
would imagine that if you get used to
doing new york-style like six sets a
night or whatever after a year or six
months or whatever it is the progress
that you must feel yes in terms of being
a comedian then you have to and you may
disagree but then you have to tour that
material because a lot of it won't work
nationwide or needs to be retooled to do
that the tolls in New York yeah and even
if it isn't sometimes just people in New
York will laugh at stuff that people in
Omaha Nebraska won't necessarily find
funny so I really I just did an HBO
special and I really had to take the
time to you know I did a 30 day tour
where we did two shows a night almost
every single day and we only took one
night off would you shoot and I shot in
Denver which OH Denver's awesome yeah
Denver's great and so I did the
Paramount Theatre downtown and we're
editing it right now but it's it really
required me go i go to i go
Appleton Wisconsin I go to Kansas you
know I I do Chanute Kansas I did a set
in Chanute Kansas at this bar because my
uncle lives there and so I just try and
test it everywhere sure and then ideally
and some but some of my stuff is very
bizarre and a little often absurdist so
I got to figure out kind of what did
that connects and what people are like
why is he talking like that what's also
like you talking about right as you
become a bigger star like Silicon Valley
obviously exploded pretty well yeah and
then and I mean I'm looking at not only
this movie office Christmas party but
all the movies that you have coming out
after it and it's just going to be more
and more sort of people who know you
from that when they go and see you and
it's like kind of TJ Miller one TJ
Miller yeah they think I think fans of
Silicon Valley are kinda I thought he
was gonna talk she done more people or
something like that right
or be a little bit more mean-spirited or
something but I do see I riff a lot and
so if you come see me live I am sort of
you know teasing the audience and
fooling around and just riffing and
improvising stuff so for a lot of people
that they enjoy that no matter what but
yeah I think that happens but that's
fine with me I mean if you're if I'm
bringing people in and it's not just in
the stand-up isn't there taste like I
prefer him as an actor and that's fine
then I'll continue to work for them as
an actor don't see the movies but yeah
but a stand-up and I hopefully the HBO
special people will kind of get a sense
of you know they'll be able to either
watch it or why but it's true you can go
on youtube and watch somebody you know I
think if somebody doesn't research Jim
Norton's act beforehand and goes and is
like offended virus right that's on you
but I always know who didn't do the
research when I'm six minutes in and I
see the one finger go up which means
check you can always tell do you enjoy
that an hour or not all of you but have
fun like you want to enjoy it the goal
is really never to it's like if you
offend them incidentally you do but it's
not like I don't try to it just it
happens I don't want to and I think you
know for all comics you really you can
use an entire set can be ruined even if
you're killing everywhere in the room if
just one woman in front just has her
arms crossed in just a sour face like
this isn't for me you can really that
can make you
feel bad you just start focusing on
trying to get her to laugh and trying to
could you want to attack us with you but
you can't because they're not being rude
or disrespecting my remember and it was
a great set and these people had
committed the wrong show and they just
had such confident too because they were
it was almost like they'll just the
looks on their faces like certain things
that were really working like I know
this is funnier than you're giving it
and I know you're not laughing for a
certain reason just this big [ __ ]
cranky looking woman in the shitty
looking [ __ ] guy I [ __ ] hated them
you're lucky you made it out of there
cuz yeah your instinct is just like what
is your problem why aren't you having a
fun time everybody else is that's that's
the attitude you want right and then you
can really slice into them but I always
find you know for whatever reason I
think in part that maybe the characters
that I play but people yell [ __ ] out in
my shows a lot I don't know how much
people kind of but I always have it's
usually a positive heckler somebody's
dry and thinks they're being funny but I
still cut into them and if there's just
a bunch of mouthy bachelorettes or just
girls that you know those entitled girls
sure they're in Milwaukee and they're
they think they're much hotter than they
are and they they sort of they just
they're so they're talking and gossiping
talking about whether they're going to
do after the show and texting I will
just ruin a table of girls like that
yeah which is so great about having
comedy because like most actors have to
kind of be PC and make sure that their
fans stay their fans and all like you're
not supposed to insult your fans right
you have to whatever studio doesn't want
somebody who's gonna like do press and
be like hey everybody going to see
office Christmas party on Friday [ __ ]
you yeah come on buying goes to Studio B
[ __ ] idiot no but when they're
talking during your show you can get
that out well an assist and if you can
say whatever the [ __ ] you want right you
know I mean that's that's the thing is
like in in this movie I actually had a
couple times where I disagreed heartily
with the directors for the most part or
sensibilities were the same and but I
times and said I just don't think that
that's necessary are really that funny
and they're like well you got to do it
you got to give us one and the producers
they're going sorry man you know and so
you don't have that in stand-up so let
me ask you wait went now what was it
with you guys didn't click on a couple
of
was it you thought it was too mean or
too sweet I just didn't think yeah cuz
the movie actually is has a lot of heart
to it and it's it really is a holiday
movie which is a strange juxtaposition
with an r-rated film but um you know
they were just a couple like one joke
was like kind of like it sort of I don't
know it was like you know I'm straight
well you know one time and that other
time and another time and I kind of you
know it just seemed like it had a little
bit too much of an agenda for whatever
reason cuz the one of the directors is
gay and he just you know I know what his
agenda was and I get it but I didn't
think for the character it really made
sense was the agenda do you think was to
further like a play it's to say it's
okay to have hooked up with someone of
the same sex you know that was sort of
what he was trying to say right which i
think is fine and a good message but for
me it didn't match the character to the
character for me this one this guy is
not really sexual he's like a kid he's
excited about Christmas he wants to
throw a party he wants everybody to have
fun but he's not trying to hook up at
the Christmas party he's hosting right
it'd be like if rocky went you know you
know sucked a dick before why so we kind
of we found our way to a version of it
that I thought was good but it was stuff
like that and it was only one two or
three things because these guys are
really funny the great thing about the
the movie is it like right now let me
put it this way it's very easy to
promote a comedy during the apocalypse
you know I mean right now now right
people need to just party their way
through the end of this year they just
need to drink too much eggnog and go and
see stuff like this that makes them
laugh or just stay at home and watch you
know funny movies but office Christmas
party definitely if you want to go to
the theater and not have to speak with
your family for an hour and a half you
know that's always nice and then maybe
you can talk about how funny the movie
was for the next half hour it's two
hours stress free holiday yeah before
the alcohol steps in right next holiday
once again so when you find out you're
doing a Jennifer Aniston movie to like
she's like one of the most famous women
you know it was it was crazy
so are you like do you lose your might
like as in my that story you just told
maybe it's just my low self-esteem
talking I be sitting there like whatever
the director wants like okay you're not
gonna throw me out of this movie right
but in your case it'll be true
yeah we mess it up i think i you know i
I've I'd sort of I hosted Critics Choice
and kind of had this moment with her as
I was sort of doing a bit in the
audience with Schumer and as I sort of
you know on the way out I'd she was like
hey this is really funny and this is
just and I could just tell she was just
very nice yeah and very sweet and then
you meet her and it's always weird to
meet these people in person
Jason Bateman I worked with before on
this Mike judge movie called extract but
um you know I never met her just like
the first time I met Wahlberg it's just
weird to be in their presence and they
do have this kind of famous forcefield
thing where you you know you're sort of
like but I you know I quickly just
tested the waters and said well let's
get the irritating questions out of the
way do you have to drink some or smart
water is that like part of the contract
she was like yeah well I have to have
but you know in public I do have to
drink smart water but privately you know
I'll drink other waters like like I'm
allowed to do what I wanted my own head
but you know that and then but she was
so nice and so easy to work with and she
still you always forget she's still an
actress so sometimes she'll do a scene
it should be like I don't think I'm
getting any of this right you think that
was funny so there's these weird kind of
real insecurities that keep her work in
check so that she's not like I'm the
greatest ever but her and Bateman work
together a lot I think because they can
really move the dial just a little bit
I mean it's so subtle with Bateman and
so he'll do different reads of the same
sentence and they'll just be minut
differences but all of them will be
funny in their way Aniston's really like
that too she kind of takes she's good
with sort of reactionary comedy so it
was interesting to work with them also
because they were sort of playing the
straight man to my character who's just
a little bit more broad a little bit
more bland but the best part about the
movie is that the the actual party does
get out of control in a way that I've
never seen a party portrayed and it's
not trying to be it's not like project
experts like crazies party ever it just
escalates and gets out of there can I
read that a
uh that you just kind of the directors
just told the extras to just [ __ ]
party and then you know they were like
pretending to blow each other yes that a
true thing there there was a girl
sitting on filing file cabinet and you
know this was a weird conversation when
the guy was like so you know they said
we could do whatever I wanted to it's
crazy as possible so I should put my
head in between your legs and be like
going down on you during this party and
this is how it is actually I would
somehow creepily he got her to be like
yeah I guess it's okay they forgot that
we shoot for 12 hours second I have to
be doing the same thing so you know at
our 8th they were both like Loretta dad
to see if she forgot he remembered her
clearly she she pie was again you Big B
between her legs and not doing anything
I'm I suspect I came down here yeah in
between your musty legs because it's
been eight hours he went to lunch well
no that's a good point yeah see now you
see port-a-potty come purchase you're
just perverted enough to maybe make that
up side but I think that guy definitely
was soz and then it was very surreal
because everybody's dancing and partying
and trying to be as crazy as possible
but it's silent right because they're
shooting our dialogue so everybody's
pretending to dance and drink and blow
each other one another you know there's
kind of Lingus left and right that's
great and they you know it's they have
to do it in silence for 12 hours a day
and sometimes 1416 hours for three
months yeah they're the unsung hero it
was that long yeah Wow with this bit
that I this came up because I was
talking about cunnilingus you have this
bit about how you like a really meaty
vagina yes that's one of my I think
which special do you mean it's always
been talking about ira morning yeah
you're like the audience knows but that
bit made me laugh so much
and i I concur I agree oh you don't
think I really enjoyed it I think that's
an important part of it it adds a lot
more to the equation yeah guys I mean
rather than one where it's just just
kind of peeking out yeah come on all the
way out here let's talk yeah you're a
[ __ ] yeah look at accordion just fell
out
yes exactly it's a Jacob's Ladder good
were you making fun of a Sandy Canyon at
the Saturday screening which oh yeah
Channel seven rolling cuz rolling you
know Roy book it rolling he went to the
screen oh yeah roll rolling went to the
screening and he was just texting me and
he goes he goes you're the moon scrub
daddy he went to the screening and he
goes the movie was great but you gotta
ask TJ Miller he can't he was he was
insulting sandy Canyon and one of the
people from et or something like I said
it was so great so I'm I held the
screening for 15 minutes because it's
all of the press so I wanted to make
sure all the press got there to see it
because it's a really [ __ ] funny movie
and by the way most of the screenings
the stars of the movies aren't there
yeah like when the star of the movie
holds the screening it's like yeah well
and AII right if you're it's not a great
movie I would not have showed up right
and introduce it and rollin actually I
trust his sense of humor he's the scrub
daddy and but he did he totally said
that was so so great when you call those
guys out I held the screen for 15
minutes then as I'm walking in to start
it I also you know two of our friends
were late Cates like curators a week so
we finally started screening we know al
depressin as I'm walking out to go in
front of the audience
sandy KITT what is it Kenyon sandy
Kenyon from ABC they attended from
channel 7 ABC that's it backstage with
sandy Kenyon oh my gosh she looks
exactly like how he acted s he just goes
he goes hey me and AJ eaten from from a
team from extra yeah but he goes from
extra we want to we say let's get this
show on the road we got stuff to do we
got important things to is he's saying
that I got to just walk on stage and be
like ah well I was just that's a good
introduction so I just want to ask who
just said that because I think that's
good you're going to be disgruntled
viewers of this film and so I totally
called them out and he's like sandy from
channel 7 I was like okay and what about
you and he goes I'm AJ Eaton from et I
was like oh okay well that makes sense
why you guys are upset because et is
just a poor man's
extra and and Channel seven I've never
[ __ ] watch that so everybody laughed
and they kind of knew we were teasing
then later AJ interviewed me and
Courtney Vance for press for the film
and he said he goes but I totally
tricked you man because I'm on extra and
you said he teased the poor man's and I
was like buddy if you had told me that
you're on extra I would have said that's
the poor man's eat his face just drop he
thought he's gonna end the interview
being like busted I told you the wrong
thing I was like dude you yeah it was a
slam it didn't matter what you're saying
like insane yeah you're missing the
thing he didn't like I love those at
Sandy Canyon shout it out like AJ's
behind him because you know what that
means that means that sandy knows that
he has no clout and so he's gotta say
yeah me and AJ vestra like we don't be
right both agree we've got to get this
let's get this screening started we've
got important things to say sandy Kenyon
what important things in life are you
gonna go home and get back to your book
I mean what the hell look at how it
looks better let me introduce you a
comedy show come on me and Chappelle
gotta go
no he's the important one right yeah
yeah no one drives about you sandy sandy
Kenyon what kind of review to give you
um yeah I don't think he's who knows we
do out but who cares also I mean he kind
of it's not for I mean I think he ended
up really liking the movie but it's it's
comedy is not for people that are sort
of sour [ __ ] pieces of [ __ ]
yeah you're kind of yelling that [ __ ]
out like I think you're starting to you
know you're right starting below zero
yeah we're not gonna be able to move the
dial enough to make you happy but I
don't know he was it's just that we have
important things to do like like one yet
he wasn't joking no he was not joking he
wasn't being ironic or being silly oh he
was like why are we waiting a full 15
minutes to see this movie for free like
you got my job my job is to see this
watch a movie for free and then go on TV
for three minutes and talk about it yes
that's the gig and what he didn't
realize is he'll probably just like it's
hilarious it was really funny so it just
I don't know I like publicly
embarrassing him though we also has the
perfect name to make sense
woman I you know who it was they said
yeah TJ was heckling sandy Kenyon I'm
like whoo I love that here is I honestly
know I've seen that Facebook really
feminine individual yeah yeah office
Christmas party facial feature this does
it's in theaters on Friday everybody
should go see it office Christmas party
I mean et vagina
yeah the cast is ridiculous Jennifer
Aniston Jason Bateman Kate McKinnon
Olivia Munn Courtney B Vance its credit
course and all the female Vanessa Bayer
oh my god and Sony who's the taxi driver
in Deadpool Andrew Leeds Oliver Jacob
Cooper Sam Richardson from veep it's
like there's too many people I've
Randall Park who was in fresher of you
and for he isn't me in that in that
Kevin will be too maybe I think maybe
but he's also in trainwreck what
everything was one of the magazine
editors along with them right he was
great in that yeah he's really funny and
he's great in this he's kind of weird
and kind of creepily - nice then you
find out he's got a strange fetish it's
fun Courtney Vance is coming in here
tomorrow yeah yeah he's great - yes
really like he's very silly you know in
this movie he goes totally nuts I'm an
aids you know cuz he's such a dramatic
actor and you'll see on the radio that
he's just he's very like a silly funny
guy so weird
yeah cuz I know I'm from the Oh Jay show
and from this is us yeah it'll be fun
and we watched his if you go online and
watch he does fences with James Earl
Jones
Denzel watching he did that lot agent
won a Tony for it and you could tell
from the clip of him and James Earl
Jones it's going to be way better than a
Denzel
but Courtney be Vance is [ __ ] he's one
of the best dramatic actors work out
there and this is his first comedy
that's great before you get before we
headed up for he's a [ __ ] and the show
are you have you guys started are you
doing yet what we're doing we're doing
Deadpool - and then Silicon Valley is in
its fourth season we're seeing that
right now I think that's actually gonna
be really good my life has been such a
blur and then post-election everything
so [ __ ] up that like I haven't gotten
to edit my HBO and I special and I also
it's been a blur what this season is
going to be so I almost and we're
shooting it out of order so I almost I'm
excited to see this season as much a
show actually like yeah cuz I have no
idea what this season is
and up you know looking like is that
what the facial hair is is that a
character things I try and change the
facial hair and make it stranger and
stranger and then this season I've had
them slowly bring the mutton chops up a
mustache that just connects so that's
been that's been a little fun thing for
me because in your fourth season you
really know the character everybody does
in you know they're they're very good
writers so you can settle into doing
things that make you laugh make you
happy yeah yeah yeah well the show is
really really good and that's man I'm
excited for everybody to see office
Christmas party that's great - it's not
TJ Miller on Twitter yes better believe
it I'm glad you napped jack is [ __ ] that
right and but I am on Instagram is
teenage millionaire thank you for saying
that exactly I'm also excited to come
and like watch you and the other
luminaries in New York work because
that's something I've seen all the
people in Los Angeles a lot you know
right and I've it's not like if I see
Patton or Sarah or any of those people
again I don't learn something from them
or marvel at their talent but there's so
many great people on the East Coast and
the alt scene sort of there was a mass
exodus to Los Angeles so that'll be easy
for me to access and get stage time with
regards to that but it is weird I as a
you know as a early 20s kid coming out
of college I did think being in New York
comic is the coolest thing that a human
being could do and I still that's with
me today that's right I'm so excited
about that I think it's it's just a
really fascinating job and I can tell by
Seinfeld likes that illusion of the -
the construction workers that it just
really feels like you're grinding yeah
you're chiseling away at this thing and
then once you've got it you present it
and then move on to keep chiseling into
the next thing what I'm really good to
learn from is you if you want to learn
how a person can make a half-empty room
feel like a theater